we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192davidp
there's a really great question brought
up in today's voicemail take a listen to
this
hello david i was watching your show
today and uh
or listening to your show and there was
that uh interview with the guns rights
activist and marjorie taylor green and i
was just wondering because you started
talking about socialists
um why does everyone think that
socialists are anti-gun
when you know marx and lenin and mao all
wrote you know explicit or explicitly
pro-gun
um do they just i mean i know they're
operating bad face but do they just
fundamentally not have any idea i guess
what socialism is
or i don't know
yeah this this is a this is a really
excellent question um
there is this reflexive inclusion
whenever people talk about
socialists wrongly and again there's
almost no socialist in positions of
power in the united states
it's a complete and total farce but you
will often hear about the socialists who
want to disarm you
that is a completely uh non-based in
history claim
and there are lots of examples of this
if you look back at an 1850
speech written by karl marx and engels
they say under no pretext should arms
and ammunition be surrendered
any attempt to disarm the workers must
be frustrated by
force if necessary there are many
socialist theorists who
supported armed workers in part of their
support
of the proletariat maintaining power
recognizing that
maybe the gun would be a useful way for
them to gain
power over the capitalists mao
under mao villages factories
all sorts of different units this uh you
know discrete units
were expected and encouraged to have
armed militias that were self-organized
and were
they they had weapons um under lenin
lennon wrote on disarmament where
lenin said an oppressed class
which does not strive to learn to use
arms
to acquire arms only deserves to be
treated like slaves lenin's perspective
as i understand it is
uh having weapons prevents you from
being treated like a slave
by the capitalist by the employer by the
owners of the means of production so
not only do they not i mean yes the if
if you're wondering
does the right understand x the the
answer is probably not
and not only do they misunderstand what
socialism is and who is a socialist
they very casually and wrongly talk
about
anti-gun socialists when historically
there is much pro-gun sentiment among
some of the
most important and notable uh socialist
marxist figures in history but i don't
think they care i don't think
watching this clip is going to change
their minds they'll just keep repeating
the same stuff
on the bonus show today we will talk
about jeff bezos
uh planning to step down as amazon's ceo
we will talk about the capital rioters
quickly selling each other out
to try to lower their own possible
prison sentences and we will talk about
oregon decriminalizing possession of
drugs huge step in oregon we will talk
about the implications oregon
as someone's somewhat someone i know
says it but i say oregon
all of those stories and more on today's
bonus show
sign up at joinpakman.com to get
instant access